lellouche il est est un peu gauche se
pygargues de stellaire est née le 26
mars à l'espace rambouillet et il y à
déjà a bien grandi à l'âge adulte il
peut peser jusqu'à 9 kg et mesurer deux
mètres cinquante d'envergure en milieu
naturel sont énormes beck lui permet de
pêcher des poissons et même des jeunes
phoques mais on le trouve plus beaucoup
dans la nature
en 15 ans la population de cette espèce
a presque diminué de moitié
c'est un mail aux pêcheurs qui mangent
les poissons en russie et beaucoup de
pme compagnies pétrolières qui
s'installe et qui déverse beaucoup de
produits dans les fleuves qui sont
ingérés par le poisson et comme l'aigle
pêcheur
bonjour poisson voilà ça lui qui en
pâtit mais c'est le 20ème spécimen est
ici est le seul en france cette année
une fierté pour le parc la conservation
des espèces et l'une de ses missions
principales
depuis 1995 l'espace rambouillet
participe activement au programme
international de sauvegarde du pygargue
de stellaire aujourd'hui on a mis en
place avec nos naissances de pygargues
dostaler on la refait 5 5 couples qui
sont répartis dans d'autres parcs donc
en france à l'étranger
l'objectif c'est de multiplier les
couples d'avoir beaucoup de jeunes et
peut-être que dans 20 30 ans pour à
réintroduire des jeunes dans le milieu
naturel
on peut observer l'aigle pendant la
démonstration de vol aux côtés de ses
congénères une espèce peut-être rare
mais pas pour le public de l'espace
rambouillet